I got a voicemail today at two one
nine two David Pakman asking about
impending Trump pardons. Take a listen.
It is this just in Colorado? Yes, I know that
Biden is one presumptively one. I think
you've said in the past that you think
Trump will probably be pardoning
all sorts of criminal friends.
And I'm wondering two things, I guess.
What else do you think is going to do in
this lame duck period? And in particular,
do you think he's going to pardon himself?
OK, so at this point, there is no doubt that
Donald Trump is going to pardon a bunch of his
criminal friends. The stuff about, you know, Trump
resigning so Pence can pardon him preemptively.
I don't think it's hugely likely, but that's
partially because it would be such a crazy event.
It's certainly conceivable that it could happen.
I think there's a good chance Trump does what he's
been doing for the last week for the rest of
his term, which is nothing. And Michael Cohen,
his former lawyer, said he thinks
Trump will leave the White House
for the Christmas holiday and just never go back
to D.C. that he won't be at Biden's inauguration.
I don't know. But there is no doubt that the
pardoning is going to happen of other people, of
other people, trump pardoning all sorts of people.
We have a great bonus show for you today. Make
sure to get instant access by grabbing
a membership at Join Patman Dotcom.